on saturday we marked the 20th
anniversary of september 11 2001 the day
when the terror group al-qaeda crashed
two passenger planes into the world
trade center in new york another jet
crashed into the pentagon outside
washington dc and a fourth crashed into
a pennsylvania field after passengers
famously fought back
thousands died and the world has never
been the same since
the first plane hit the north tower at 8
46 a.m initially there was widespread
confusion about exactly what had
happened
but while covering the aftermath of the
first plane news cameras caught the
second flying into the south tower
as the towers burned before the eyes of
the world it emerged that two more
planes had been hijacked
one which crashed into the pentagon at 9
37 am
meanwhile the twin towers were consumed
in flames as fuel from the jets burned
out of control
it's estimated that hundreds of people
jumped to their deaths to escape the
unimaginable heat of the fires
the towers collapsed raising a cloud of
toxic dust over downtown new york
people fled in terror unable to see
covered in debris and soot trying to get
away
in the end almost three thousand people
from dozens of nations died that day the
us government declared its war on terror
soon after and now twenty years later
it's unclear if there was a winner
an attack that shocked the us and its
allies into action
after september 11th the u.s and western
europe felt threatened by a new menace
international terrorism on a mass scale
the reaction from washington was swift
make no mistake
the united states
will hunt down
and punish those responsible
for these cowardly acts
within a month the u.s launched
operation enduring freedom also known as
the war on terror first stop afghanistan
where the taliban hosted al qaeda
this was the first time nato joined the
u.s in pursuing military action
major combat operations in afghanistan
were over within months but the war on
terror became a catch-all phrase used to
justify a wide variety of policies
the u.s passed the patriot act giving
the government sweeping surveillance
powers
america jailed war prisoners and
suspected terrorists in a notorious
prison at guantanamo bay cuba
where some are still awaiting trial
almost two decades later
airport security worldwide was ramped up
every stricter procedures covering
liquids and even shoes were introduced
as new bomb plots against planes were
discovered
and the war on terror was used as a
partial justification for the war in
iraq in 2003
with significantly less international
support than the war in afghanistan
the death toll in iraq spiraled into the
hundreds of thousands as the u.s
intervention unleashed sectarian warfare
within a few years the tide of
international opinion turned against the
u.s the revelation of torture practices
at u.s facilities in afghanistan and
iraq as well as secret sites rocked the
international community
when the u.s later reduced its forces in
iraq the so-called islamic state arose
out of the chaos on the ground taking
territory and inspiring its followers to
commit bloody attacks around the world
meanwhile in afghanistan the taliban
were back
civilian deaths continued to mount
with international patients fraying and
the cost exceeding a trillion dollars
the u.s tried to change course
in 2013 president barack obama announced
the end of operation enduring freedom
tonight i can announce that over the
next year another 34 000 american troops
will come home from afghanistan this
drawdown will continue and by the end of
next year our war in afghanistan will be
over
[Applause]
that ended up taking seven more years
al qaeda and the groups inspired by it
have not been able to pull off another
911 but the price in deaths strained
alliances and now the return of the
taliban to power after 20 years has been
extremely high
well joining us for more now from new
york city is lauren manning she survived
the 9 11 terror attacks and has written
extensively about the events of
september 11 2001. lauren welcome to the
program i wonder 20 years on have you
managed to rationalize what happened to
you that day
well uh the word rationalization is one
that i could never apply to
the
history of what happened certainly to
myself
in 2001
or in 1993 i was also there during the
first bombing
i think uh
to just play on that word it is the most
irrational act when people uh take
their personal animus out on civilians
and unfortunately uh that is what
happened that day it was the worst
domestic attack on u.s
soil and it affected
tens of thousands of people ultimately
that were not only rooted as i was but
murdered and lately so many with disease
surrounded by utter madness at those
moments when were you first able to
realise to put the pieces together and
understand that you were indeed in the
middle of a terror attack
well
as i entered the building the first
jet was crashed
into the upper floors united flight 711
the
fuel exploded and pummeled down the
elevator shafts i was enveloped in the
fire i had no idea at that moment what
was going on i was in the fight for my
life just to breathe to try to get back
out the doors it was only when the
backdraft released and blew out the
windows that i was in many ways pushed
out with hurricane force winds back on
the street where i'd been moments before
and
after i finally got across the six lanes
of highway to drop and roll and look
back up
uh
it was not that long thereafter that the
second plane hit the south tower and at
that moment i knew that it was not a
commercial plane or a you know small
plane that made a mistake that it was an
intended attack
you suffered the most devastating
injuries with burns to more than 80 of
your body your chances of survival were
almost zero zero
do you ever ask yourself not just the
nature of how you survived but when so
many others perished do you ask yourself
why you survived
i don't actually ask myself why
i
understood in those moments
that the easier choice would have been
to die but i did not even believe that
death would release me from the pain
and so i made a choice and i decided to
live
that i actually did survive was
because of tenacity resilience luck
and
uh less luck than many had that day who
were
not scathed or who weren't there but i
knew as i watched bodies come pummeling
to the ground
that some of those were my colleagues my
friends from kenner fitzgerald and i had
the slimmest chance to fight and the way
i figured it was i had a 10 month old
son i didn't want to abandon him
and i wasn't going to let them get one
more on the kill list
and so
it was as simple as that equation
when you talk about those atrocious
things you talk about 9 11 today what is
there is there one dominant emotion from
all of that
the most dominant emotion for me is the
heroism
that people
who were not clothed in uniforms showed
each other that day the grace
of
colleagues and friends and strangers
helping
each other
i had someone help me that day in 1993
i helped a woman down the blackened
stairwell
i think that
the most resonant piece for it
is
the grace we show one another
in the times that seem the darkest and
most hopeless
and
the notion that we all have such
unmeasured strength
and it's moments that galvanize a people
a society the world much as we've seen
now in the pandemic the
situation going on in afghanistan and in
many other areas of the world when we
come together and we lay down our arms
at the sides of looking into someone's
eyes you see nothing but the earnest
desire to help and and pray and hope for
someone else that they too
um
may get better and i think that is
really
what i feel most deeply about the day
you know we honor the dead and we
hope for better times uh but man's
primitive nature certainly shows us
that's probably not the way it'll go
as you speak to
a better day coming 9 11 is a day that
shook the world do you think americans
who witnessed that day
will ever truly recover
my father was a former marine and he
said things are going to happen you're
not the first one they've happened to
and when they do there's only one way to
go
have your pity party and you've got to
move forward
so i think it's indelibly imprinted on
the minds of every every american it is
part of our history it is part of world
history
uh but i think at this point 20 years
later
we
have the
ability to look at it with a greater
perspective
sadly one we needed
in light of events that have been
transpiring over the last year and a
half
lauren it's great to speak to you and we
wish you the best 911 survivor author
entrepreneur and businesswoman well dw
zenis paul is at ground zero in new york
city for us
enos welcome what's the city like as
americans uh
preparing to mark this 20th anniversary
anthony we've been here since the early
morning hours and more and more people
come from all around the country
to commemorate this very moment i just
talked to michael who lost his mom in
the south tower he put out a sign here
at the memorial
with pictures of his wife whom he just
married telling the story telling his
mom how much he still misses her and
that's the mood here people
are very silent people are crying
they're holding hands this brings back
all the horror from 20 years ago
enos how will new yorkers be marking
this day
well there is a huge
ceremon a ceremony tomorrow here
in
new york at ground zero it will start
exactly at 8 49 in the morning that's
when the first plane hit
the tower uh it will begin with a moment
of silence then the family members of
the nearly 3 000 victims will read the
names and throughout two and a half
hours or so there will be moments of
silence to remember
the other planes hitting into the other
towers when the towers went down also
when the plane crashed into
the pentagon and the other plane was
brought down in pennsylvania so this
will a moment where all the names will
be read but also with with the six or
seven
minutes of silent in the whole city of
new york
it says americans remember the events
that started the the war on terror it's
the end of the war now an undignified
exit from afghanistan is that now in any
way part of this 9 11 narrative
for the political uh people i shall say
uh for people who are really interested
in politics this plays a huge huge role
in the whole
day will be kind of overshadowed by the
withdrawal from afghanistan antony but
if you talk to the people here at the
very ground zero they really their
hearts really go out to the victims
because we have to keep in mind this was
really
a day where not only 3 000 or nearly 3
000 people got killed but really this
hit the united states in the heart it
shook this country in many many western
alliance as well and this i think is the
the dominating feeling at least here at
ground zero in new york
inis poll in new york city thank you
very much
well the 911 attacks had a german
connection to of course three of the
four hijackers who piloted the planes
were based in the northern german city
of hamburg where they attended
university the egyptian muhammad atta
was the man considered their leader
hamburg
a big city a university town
inside this building is retired
professor ditmar mahulu's office
he guided muhammad atta's doctoral
dissertation on city planning
bhatta was called amir at the time
professor mahula was shocked when he
found out that atta
his own student was one of the pilots of
the planes that flew into the world
trade center
is
a young student like so many others but
with the difference that he was a muslim
here in hamburg
he was very observant and engaged
when i asked myself if i missed
something nothing comes to me
lived close to the university in a
rental apartment he held meetings here
with other islamists
three of the four september 11th suicide
pilots lived in hamburg in the years
before the attack
his old professor can only guess why
this particular ambitious student became
so radicalized
like many young people who are ambitious
and intelligent muhammad wanted to make
a contribution of some kind
and he never got that kind of
recognition including from me
but apparently they have them in the
alcood's mosque
that mask was heavily influenced by
salafism a hardline branch of islam
atta and other 911 attackers attended
several times the mosque has since been
closed it was on the authority's radar
as a meeting point of potential
islamists as the authorities later
admitted
we were close
closer than we realized
we knew some of the individuals but we
couldn't see the structures that were in
place
[Music]
what they were up to was preparing the
september 11th attacks several men
traveled to afghanistan for training
then a few months before september 11th
muhammad atta showed up in professor
mahula's class
i noticed that someone was there
i looked up and it was muhammad
looking at me in his usual way
and i said muhammad great where have you
been i haven't seen you for ages
wait a moment we're almost done
i gave the rest of my lecture but when
joining us now is retired army colonel
chris colander he's the first american
to have both fought the taliban as a
commander in combat and engaged them in
peace talks he's also an author and
consultant on security and leadership
chris welcome to the program the 9 11
attacks were unprecedented so too was
the reaction 20 years later can we now
say the war on terror was the right
response
well first of all thank you for having
me on your program i remember
where i was of course many of us do on
september 11th i was at the war college
and
the first planet had already hit when
one of the instructors came in and said
hey turn on the television
and
we turned on the television in time to
see the second plane
hit the world trade center and
you know one plane might have been an
accident two planes it was an attack and
we knew all of us since we were all
serving officers there in the war
college that our lives were going to
fundamentally change
i deployed to afghanistan from germany
so my unit was
stationed in schweinfert germany and
you know when i think about
those deployments and that deployment in
particular
you know i also think about my
appreciation
for the support that we had from the
communities in schweinford and wurzburg
um and and other places where our
soldiers lived and i just wanted to
give my appreciation for that
and fair enough too uh just returning to
the question can we now say that the war
on terror uh as understandable as it was
um was the right response was it an
effective response at combating
terrorism
well there's a couple of ways to answer
that the the first one is that yeah we
live history forward
but we examine history backwards
and so at the time
when
the united states had just gotten
hit in
911
al qaeda senior leadership
was in afghanistan and
from where the attacks were planned and
supported
um and the taliban refused to hand them
over
i mean you could understand this was i i
always felt as a soldier fighting in the
war that this was a just war that we
were fighting justly
now when you look in hindsight when you
look back on
there are plenty of mistakes and
challenges i write about these and zero
sum victory
own goals if you will i write about
these in zero-sum victory and they
happen in both iraq and afghanistan
where
we made many unforced
many of these unforced errors that in
some ways in many ways
create made the terrorism problem um
worse today more more proliferating um
today than it had been in 2001. that
leads me to the next question some
estimates say we spent eight trillion
dollars and nine hundred thousand lives
were lost has all of that made us safer
than we were in 2001
well it's too soon to tell in a place
like afghanistan
so
you know in uh 2300 american service
members who were killed in action uh 2
000
dollars
you you know 2 trillion excuse me 2
trillion u.s dollars
that we spent
20 years and that that's just the united
states not to mention
uh the sacrifices that our allies have
made i mean to see
at the end of that the afghan government
evaporate the afghan people vote with
their feet
to abandon that government that had
abandoned them many many years ago
and accept the taliban i mean it's it's
difficult to it's difficult to watch
that all happen
with respect to afghanistan i think the
united states and the international
community have three main near-term
objectives
the first one is to continue the
evacuations
of people who worked for our governments
of our our citizens who want to get out
um second is are the humanitarian and
human rights concerns uh 20 million
afghans are on the verge of starvation
facing severe food and water shortages
we all know that human rights challenges
in afghanistan particularly women's
rights i mean afghanistan even before
this was rated as the second worst place
in the world to be a woman
and then you've got the economic
collapse that's ongoing
and then third is is the the
counterterrorism and you know right now
it's
entirely understandable if people want
to turn their backs in frustration on
afghanistan but i think if we do so it
makes all three problems worse
if we continue engaging
with afghanistan then we have a chance
of at least addressing those three
objectives
global security expert and analyst
christopher colander thank you so much
thank you for having me
glenn carl is a former cia officer who
spent the last of his 23 years in the
agency running interrogations looking
for the man responsible for the terror
attacks on the united states mr carl
welcome to the program you played a
central role in the war on terror which
we'll get to in a moment but i wanted to
ask firstly about your state of mind
today and how you'll be spending your
weekend marking 20 years since the 9 11
attacks
well it is 20 years but i won't be
commemorating it in any particular way i
think the most disturbing uh aspect of
the 20-year commemoration to me is
that it has been 20 years that
the united states and therefore the
world focus
has been distorted
by the quote war on terror
there are of course and there were and
still are terrorists islamic terrorists
who are trying to kill me or you
but
they need not have
defined the foreign and domestic
policies of the most powerful country on
earth for 20 years
where were you on september 11th in 2001
i had just been
reassigned changed my assignment
and had arrived in washington on
september
1st
actually on september 1st i had a final
business meeting at the world trade
tower
in new york
and then that was literally the last
thing that i did in in new york and then
i i drove down to washington the day of
the attack i was in my office
and
not directly involved in
any terrorist or terrorism-related
operation at that moment so i was an
observer
so after that shock that you surely felt
came the anger for many millions of
people but the vast majority of those
angry masses didn't get to do anything
about it whereas you months later you
were the one chosen
of the few to find the most wanted man
on the planet did you carry any personal
anger into that professional pursuit of
osama bin laden
i think yes i think all of us
were
of course angry that someone had
killed
the thousands of people who had nothing
to do with anything other than being
americans and many of them were not
americans
just victims of a terrorist act and
terrorism is designed to
change strike fear and to change the
political feelings of a population
rather than
to strike a specific objective against
of a government
so
sure i was angry in that sense but
al qaeda and its terrorist acts were
nothing new to me or to many of my
colleagues i had been working on al
qaeda
at times for five years prior to
the attack of 9 11. so many of us have
been quite focused for a long time
that anger that you you speak to it
fueled a rap a rapid response a shock
and awe response but did it help or
hinder finding bin laden
well emotions are never good things
uh and any policy making or any uh act
that needs to be or action that that
needs to be reasoned
rather than anger i think the
primary uh error
that has affected
much of the world actually is that we
have been literally i'm not being
insulting here
deluded by our fears so that we
fear is always far more powerful than
reason and
we react as humans instinctively to
a perceived threat
far out of proportion to its uh
more objective assessed
danger
and and that has driven uh certainly it
did early on uh much of the war on
terror's initial construction and
actions
and that uh that that has been treasured
you were in charge of interrogating the
man thought to be osama bin laden's
banker you eventually came to think he
was innocent in your book titled the
interrogator and education you wrestled
with the question
if what you did was torture nearly 20
years later do you have a firm answer
for yourself
well i didn't have any doubt then
there was no question that
what
part of my institution part of the ca
cia
had been instructed to do was torture
there was no question about that at all
the dilemma was for me and for for many
of my colleagues was what would i do how
could i
achieve
my orders my mission
and yet honor my oath to the
constitution and not therefore of course
engage in anything
remotely like uh torture that was the
challenge and the way i framed it at the
time in my mind
was when
will i have to say no
and that point was reached at different
times and different ways by many
different people but it was
instantaneously clear to me from the
first minute literally from the first
minute that i was briefed on the program
that we were talking about torture there
was no question in my mind
two decades after the planes hit the
twin towers 19 years after you joined
the war effort with a a key
counter-terrorism brief
can you tell me who won the war on
terror
in the narrow sense of uh the initial
united states objective uh for the cia
for the military for the government was
to destroy al-qaeda
and other jihadist
terrorist groups from that perspective
the united states and and u.s allies
have had
dramatic successes al qaeda continues to
exist but is a
shade a shadow of what it once was now
the problem for in terrorism is that it
only takes one person to kill many
others
and terrorism has
morphed
over the past 20 years from
a group like al qaeda which is
hierarchical and has a commander and
orders and plans
to
the greater threat now
which is from what we call inspired
jihadists or inspired terrorists
someone who identifies with the ideology
or the theology
and may take a vague bit of guidance
from
some entity but acts fundamentally
without any command and control
structure that's a far harder challenge
right so in the larger sense
the um
many of our actions have had
have counterproductive results and i
think the larger
challenge
has been
what does the muslim world on the whole
think about
jihadist terrorism like al-qaeda and bin
laden engaged in and there
although
the threat continues and people continue
to suffer from terrorist attacks i think
we have seen a positive evolution
among
muslims who are
substantially more hostile
overall to
something like an al qaeda attack than
they were 20 years ago so it's a mixed
balance sheet
narrowly
positive with regard to al-qaeda and
organizations
negative
in the way
the consequences for western societies
and what we have done
and and yet i think
long-term positive painful as that might
be to say
or to think um
that
islam is evolving past
a visceral hostility
towards western norms that would lead to
murder and mayhem
glenn carl a national security expert in
boston massachusetts thank you so much
almost 3 000 people died on september
11th most of the victims were in the
world trade center but thousands also
managed to escape before the towers
collapsed one of the people who was in
the world trade center that morning was
wendy lansky she told dw's oliver salad
what she experienced on that fateful
september morning
[Music]
with a beautiful day sunny clear and was
just expecting a regular boring day
i was on the 29th floor of tower one i
took the elevator up to my office i was
sitting at my desk and on tuesdays we
had a regular status meeting every week
so i was kind of shuffling some papers
and getting some agendas ready and was
literally getting up from my chair of my
desk
when i felt an incredible sound
and thud and felt the building shake and
that's when i knew it was never going to
be a regular day
[Music]
it was a large impact like a crashing
sort of a sound and then the building
swayed a little bit ever so slightly and
out of the corner of my eye i could see
debris out the window
and then i heard the sound
of people jumping and the connection of
those people to the ground which i will
never ever forget so we just headed
towards the stairwell opened up the the
doors and preceded our exodus down 29
flights of stairs
and after i saw probably the second or
third fireman
i said to him what exactly hit this
building
and he looked at me
with this just look of shock and he said
a jet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i went out into the street
and it looked like a blizzard like a
snowstorm i couldn't see two feet in
front of me
and the ground looked like the beach
everything was just white and pulverized
and people were screaming it's coming
down it's coming down run
[Music]
[Music]
i was born and raised in new york i
don't ever want that part of me to go
away and i keep it and i feel that we
need to keep it to honor the memory of 3
000 plus people who died that day and
then the thousands that have died from 9
11 cancers and diseases since then i
think if we forget or we even try to
forget we dishonor so many people
[Music]
terrorism is not necessarily just the
act of committing terrorism blowing
something up but it's what it does to
your soul the threat of terrorism is in
the heart
in my heart every day if i hear an
unexpected loud noise
if something doesn't look right if i'm
in a crowded place a regular person
might just say oh it's a loud noise the
car backfired or there's thunder my
brain says where do you go how do you
escape how do you get out what do you do
so you don't ever feel whole you don't
ever feel
normal
[Music]
well b william silcock is a leading
global innovator in journalism education
bill it's a well-worn phrase we use when
describing 911 the day that the world
changed forever but i wonder what did it
change about journalism in your eyes and
covering the government response in the
united states
uh thanks anthony for an opportunity to
share some insights i'm still
reeling in my head from that piece you
just had wow what powerful testimony
from that woman i think journalism has
changed in three important ways first of
all technology has changed in the last
20 years uh the news cycle has changed
and maybe the last thing of course is
the impact of social media
and we now have the end of the news
cycle it's now 24 7. we're always on and
back then at least there was a breathing
time for journalists to take a breath
look for some depth double check the
facts now it's non-stop information
machine out there all the time so that
does have a challenge
um the other things that have happened
in the last 20 years for for network
journalism i think there was initials
phase where they're going to be more
serious i mean we were suddenly attacked
we didn't know what's happening the
journalists need to wake up
more emphasis on serious news but if you
did a content analysis as academics do
of what's in the rundown or the lineup
of the stories every day they're kind of
right back to where they were there's
not a lot of serious news in there the
top three or four 10 stories might be
serious but then the bulk of the
newscast is a lot of
news that people can use but not news
that's going to help um get rid of the
fear factor of terrorism for sure bill
you spoke a little bit to this question
in 2001 the nightly news was very much
still king
they were the voices that spoke to both
sides of the political divide if this
happened in today's fragmented digital
landscape that you speak of would the
government response
face tougher questions
sooner i think so anthony i think they
would i think there's a lot more voices
out there not only international voices
like deutsche bella but voices from the
blogosphere voices from the
twittersphere so it's not just the white
house press corps that's pressing the
government or whoever's in charge of the
agencies what's going on there's a lot
of other people out there do the
people in power in those various uh
places in washington and around the
world always pay attention to the rest
of them that are not the traditional
news meeting of course they do and
increasingly they have to
um i think one of the other things that
happened in the in this
time of of a period of is the changing
nature early on of a very patriotic
almost jingoistic journalism style that
happened over the first two months
especially people started wearing flag
pins on local tv news anchors people
begin to question is that still
ethically okay are they showing a bias
if they have the american flag of course
not they were patriotic their country
had just you know been attacked by
terrorists but over time then people
began to ask tougher questions about
that
and what was that like what was it like
for journalists who tried to maintain
that impartial voice in these heightened
emotions a non-patriotic voice maybe uh
that you said at a time when the word
patriot it carried such weight with it
yeah well i think you know fear brought
everybody together not just first
responders it brought journalists about
average citizens we were all on the same
team we were all americans it was
america that was attacked and then
slowly over time you know more tougher
questions came in i think there's still
an interesting debate and it's this
historical debate to look back and see
uh you know who wore a flag and why why
not and and it wasn't just people you
might think today well of course it was
the very conservative media outlets but
wearing the flags no that's not true you
know it harkened back to some other days
in the turning points of television news
history in the united states the kennedy
assassination where for four days we
were glued to the screen watching this
you know four day long basically funeral
and the country came together
through that process
b william silcock associate professor at
the cronkite school thanks so much for
your insight
thank you
well the impact of 9 11 was felt
everywhere in the world almost everyone
alive then can tell you where they were
and how they heard the news well dw has
been around the world to ask people how
they remember that day and how it
changed their lives
it was definitely very very like
harrowing and haunting and i remember
being scared to fly and i think it just
kind of riddled me with a lot of anxiety
just
being so young and like not fully
understanding the gravity of what
happened but still knowing that
something like super tragic
happened as a kid seeing that it
definitely impacted like the course of
history i was like wow this is crazy
and just growing up growing in the u.s
being an avid traveler i see like how
things have been shaped it makes you
feel vulnerable doesn't it makes you
feel that you know you're not
untouchable and and you know no matter
who you are or where you are a tragedy
like that can happen
i've become much more aware of things
that that can go wrong
when taking an airplane for instance
they
was then
it was frightening because you didn't
know if it was something that was
happening locally or if it was a
worldwide attack
and as a child you were afraid that it
could happen near you that you might be
in some kind of danger
i remember panic everyone were panicked
scared
everyone thought that america is big and
protected and boom losing so many lives
i as a superpower to me i always thought
america is immune to such things but
since then i think the global security
perspective changed
the whole world was terrified
because you know that an attack of this
magnitude doesn't come out of nowhere
it's really instilled fear the fact that
if a very big
nation like united states of america can
be
affected like that
what about us as a third world country
it was obviously traumatic for me as a
kid and then my mother just turned the
tv off and takes me to
it had a big effect on an international
level especially on the wars that came
afterwards the war against terrorism and
so on these attacks fundamentally
changed the world
you